So for some reason, the Trump campaign continues
to think that it's a good idea to send people
like Eric Trump and his wife Laura Trump out
to do interviews despite being completely
unprepared and unqualified to be doing them
in favor of Donald Trump's reelection campaign.
Last week, we had this interview that Eric
Trump did with ABC News Jonathan Karl.
It went horribly wrong.
And then this weekend, we had an interview
on CNN with Jake Tapper interviewing Eric
Trump's wife, Larra Trump.
And if you're even at all human, you almost
start to feel bad for her.
You know, some of us do have this empathy
response because of how horribly wrong this
went.
We did learn over the last four years, tens
of millions of Americans have no empathy respond.
Some of us still do.
Let's look at some clips of this.
Jake Tapper mentions the town hall questioning
related to when did Trump last test negative
for Corona virus.
Is it possible Trump knew at the first debate
with Joe Biden that he had the virus?
And Larra Trump just falls apart.
President Trump gave four different answers
in about 60 seconds for different answers
on whether or not he had tested for Corona
virus before the first debate.
You were at the first debate.
Yes or no?
Did President Trump test negative?
Within 72 hours of that first debate, as was
required by the debate rules.
I assume the answer is yes.
I was not physically there with him and I
worked for you down there, not in the White
House.
I don't.
I am giving you my honest answer.
I do not know.
But I guess the answer is that you tested
negative, but you don't know for me.
I don't see why you don't know for a fact.
Why would the president knowingly test positive
and go to a debate?
I didn't say he did.
I'm just trying to get we've been trying to
get a straight answer for weeks.
Is that when he last tested negative and we
haven't gotten an answer negative.
I'm sure it is OK.
But you don't know.
So here's the question.
You're not giving a direct answer.
You you don't know.
I'll take you at your word.
So, of course, at this point, the most likely
scenario is that Trump either simply had no
test before the debate.
Remember, they said on the honor system, oh,
we're too late for the debate to test us.
But we tested negative.
They either didn't really test Trump or they
tested and came up positive and they covered
it up so that Trump could participate in Larra.
Trump asks, why would Trump do that?
Like, why would Trump deceive anybody?
The reasons range from relatively benign.
Like Trump just really wanted to go to the
debate, to the sinister, like Trump wanted
to try to infect Joe Biden.
I'm not alleging either side, but I'm telling
you, there's a very broad range of why Trump
would cover up or not be tested for a corona
virus.
The answers are all bad.
None of them is good.
This continues with Larry Trump.
Larra Trump then asked about the chance of
lock her up that her frequent at Donald Trump's
rallies when Trump attacks Gretchen Whitmer,
Gretchen Whitmer, the Democratic governor
of Michigan, against whom a plot was uncovered
to kidnap and possibly assassinate her.
And Trump has actually been ginning up more
ire against Gretchen Whitmer.
Here is Larra Trump with complete and total.
What about ISM?
Like sometimes people threaten me, too.
Victor tweeted last night, I am the governor's
deputy digital director.
I see everything that is said about and to
her online every single time the president
does this at a rally.
The violent rhetoric towards her immediately
escalates on social media.
It has to stop.
It just has to.
Don't you think that the president should
tone it down when talking about people about
whom there have been literally threats against
their lives in this very, very heightened
time?
Well, gosh, I would like to show people, my
social media and the threats against me, the
threats against my children.
When you have members of the Democrat Party
coming out and telling people, get in their
face, go harass them.
I mean, this is not just on why Joe Biden
listens to Joe Biden is and isn't saying things
like, look, anything against you or your family
or your children is horrible, detestable.
And I condemn it right now.
And if there were any Democratic politicians
that were, you know, throwing fuel on the
fire, I would say tone it down.
Why are you toning it down?
But I don't look at threats based on what
party are the recipients.
My question is, shouldn't everybody just tone
it down, including your dad, your father in
law?
Well, look at this.
He wasn't doing anything.
I don't think to provoke people to threaten
this woman at all.
She was having fun at a Trump rally.
Quite frankly, there are bigger issues than
this.
He was just having fun at a Trump rally encouraging
more disdain, which we know led to ire and
threats of violence and a plot to kidnap a
Democratic public official.
Don't you get it, guys? Trump was having fun,
and that's what matters.
When I watched this the first time preparing
it for you guys, I was reminded of something
my mom used to say growing up whenever I would
bug my little brother and just have fun at
his expense.
And I would say, oh, it's just fun.
It's just funny.
My mom would say and I remember it like it
was yesterday.
Well, it's cause she said it a week ago when
I was bugging him.
But she said if both people aren't having
fun, it's not valid fun.
And I think that that would absolutely apply
here.
Then Lara Trump was asked to explain why she
appeared to publicly mock Biden for his stuttering
problem that he has had for a very long time.
And Larra, Trump says, no, that wasn't mocking
him for stuttering.
It was mocking him for cognitive decline.
I had no idea that Joe Biden had a stutter.
Joe Biden, as we all know, his work to overcome
a stutter.
One of the speakers at the Democratic convention
was a young boy who the vice president inspired
named Bradin Harrington.
Take a listen.
It was really amazing to hear that someone
like me became move of 15 miles per hour,
per hour, per person per hour.
President.
Braydon Herrington, a very brave young boy,
you made this comment earlier in the campaign
about Joe Biden.
Let's take a listen to that.
Every time he comes on stage, they turn to
him, I'm like, Joe, can you get it out?
Let's get the words out.
Joe, you kind of feel bad for him.
How do you think it makes a little kids with
stutters feel when they see you make a comment
like that?
First and foremost, I had no idea that Joe
Biden ever suffered from a stutter.
I think what we see on stage with Joe Biden,
Jake, is very clearly a cognitive decline.
That's what I'm referring to.
It makes me uncomfortable you out.
You are the man who is so amazing.
It's so amazing to me that I can try and figure
out an answer cognitive decline during me
that what I was suggesting was I think that
mocking his stutter.
I think you are mocking a stuttering.
I think you have absolutely no standing to
diagnose somebody is cognitive decline is.
But I would think that somebody in the family
would be more sensitive to people who do not
have medical licenses.
Diagnosing politicians from afar.
Plenty of people have diagnosed your father
from afar.
And I'm sure it offends you, your father in
law from afar.
I'm sure it offends you.
You don't have any standing to say.
No, it's not what I'm saying.
You just talked about a cognitive decline,
something that Joe Biden I have one last question
for you are you can't.
Times on stage just uncomfortable as bad of
a person as Larra Trump is?
It actually makes me a little uncomfortable.
Me, I guess I don't have that sociopath gene
that so many people have to watch her implode
so badly.
Doesn't this campaign have to stop sending
her out?
Because these interviews.
This can't be helping.
Cannot.
And the real hypocrisy, of course, here is
Trump is a mess as far as this type of thing
goes.
Trump glitches and malfunctions constantly.
Yo, summer nights, he comes off of Air Force
One and can't find his limo wanders off, has
to be brought back by the arm by Secret Service
says, whereas Rudy Rudy is sitting right in
front of them, Ulysses S. Grant.
He wants to know the oranges of an investigation.
He said people want Donald Trump.
Who is she even to be talking about cognitive
decline when she's supporting Donald Trump?
It just none of it makes any sense.
Really, really bad instance for Laura Trump.
But again, I think they've got to stop sending
her out.
But who am I to suggest to them they think
this helps them, then by all means, continue
doing it.